[Musique]
salut dans la foulée du dernier sketch
sur le sens de la vie je voudrais vous
proposer une petite expérience de pensée
imaginez que vous rencontrez quelqu'un
après alice et que vous apprenez que
lorsqu'elle se rend du boulot disons à
18h30 elle se fait à dîner et elle se
couche elle se couche à 7h30 et c'est
pas parce que c'est une aspirante pdg de
start up qui se lève à 3h du mat pour
faire son jogging et répondre à ses
mails nous non elle se couche à 7h30 et
elle se lève à 7h30 vous avez déjà
deviné la suite à cause du titre de la
vidéo j'imagine allait se couche parce
qu'elles préfèrent dormir et notamment
rêver le week-end c'est pareil vendredi
soir coucher 7h30 elle se lève vers 11h
le samedi pour avaler un truc et faire
des courses une lessive et puis à 16h à
nouveau au lit etc
et maintenant je voudrais ajouter trois
variantes possibles
1 le sommeil d'alice ressemble au nôtre
il est fait semer profond et de rêves
plus ou moins chaotique dont elle ne se
souvient pas toujours au réveil
2 le sommet d'alice est très particulier
chaque fois qu'elle se couche alice
reprend le fil du rêve qui avait été
interrompu lors du dernier réveil c'est
donc comme si elle ne faisait qu'un seul
très long rêve dans lequel elle se
replonge à chaque fois que se couche
enfin même chose que précédemment mais
on ajoute une dimension supplémentaire
c'est un rêve lucide non seulement c'est
le même rêve mais en plus alice a
conscience de rêver ce qui donne à
l'expérience une dimension
supplémentaire en tous les cas ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est qu' alice n'a pas de
vie sociale elle n'a pas non plus de
passion de hobby du moins pas dans le
monde que nous partageons avec elle mais
alice n'est pas dépressive elle ne
choisit pas de dormir parce qu'elle
chercherait à fuir le quotidien pas même
comme quelqu'un qui le temps d'un film
oublie ses soucis de boulot son
quotidien c'est le sommeil ses rêves
contiennent des moments de joie de peur
de tristesse tout une intensité
affective elle y vit des réussites et
des échecs elle éprouve des interactions
pour alice la vraie vie celle sommeil la
vie éveillée c'est une obligation dont
elle s'acquitte pour payer son loyer et
nourrir afin justement de vivre la vie
qui compte vraiment pour elle celle qui
se déroule pendant son sommeil ce que
j'ai envie de vous demander c'est ce que
vous pensiez d'un tel choix de vie et si
votre avis change sensiblement entre ces
trois variantes quelle est la valeur de
ce qu'alice vie dans ses rêves si elle
gagne une compétition par exemple dans
un rêve qu'est ce que ça veut dire et de
manière générale avez vous l'impression
calice passe à côté de quelque chose en
passant la plupart de son temps endormis
ces scénarios vous semble-t-il d'écrire
des vies très différentes si vous
pouviez adopter l'un de ses scénarios le
feriez vous et si oui lequel en somme
qu'est ce que vous ressentez de manière
générale on imagine en tout ça j'ai
l'impression que cette expérience de
pensée en dit long sur ce qui à nos yeux
donne de la valeur à l'existence pour
faire écho et la vidéo précédente je
crois que ce qu'on ressent en imaginant
ce genre d'existence révèle quelque
chose du sens qu'on donne à sa vie alors
voilà j'attends vos commentaires je suis
très curieux salut